well this is uh uh this is where it gets
we we
you know we we're gonna talk about a
bunch of democrat policy stuff but let's
just let's just let's just go there
better okay you guys ready yeah yeah
from slate
my husband won't take his mask off even
for sex
uh-oh we're both vaccinated now when
will this stop
that's horrifying so so this is this is
mask derangement syndrome and i i i
blame the media
freaking out so this this guy apparently
maybe this
maybe it's a prank maybe someone wrote a
letter like haha i'm going to send you i
don't know i'm convinced that this
real people exist like this oh yeah yeah
yeah i i mean have you seen the videos
people are screaming about masks like
they
lose their minds it's it's it's just
stay away from the people if you'd like
to if they're you know not doing what
they're supposed to be like
if they're supposed to bring a mask in
the store and they don't want to and
they don't
ignore them stay away from them don't go
near them it's the weirdest thing
because if you were worried about
getting sick
why would you go up to the person and
start yelling at them you know what i
mean yeah
so anyway i'm not going to read
everything but this lady is saying that
like he won't take his mask off at all
when he's eating
uh she she says he pulls it up to expose
his mouth quickly pulls it back down
between bites
while he does not insist i do the same i
can tell it bothers him that i don't
especially because i have now started
going maskless outside per the cdc
guidelines
and plan on restaurant dining inside
soon for a girls night out
she says even during love making
is that what you call it like i don't
know that's what married people call it
no i'm saying like when you've got a guy
who's wearing a mask so he can't
you know you saw the naked gun when they
they had to use protection when they had
sex
oh yeah yeah the falls from full body
suit
that was love dude these people have
gone crazy and the thing is there's no
science
behind it we always hear trust the
science and i think people forget that
the mask was originally if you're sick
to prevent the spread right no it wasn't
oh really because in in asia
oh yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry sorry you're
correct yeah yes cause in in asia that
like for a long time mass culture has
been a thing but it was never just
everybody all the time
if you have a runny nose you think you
might be sick you don't want to spread
it
you put your mask on and then i was
going to say it first
fauci said you don't need to be walking
around with masks
maybe it protects a droplet uh that's
how it you know that's that's it's
fascinating
and then and then he flip-flopped and
then everyone needs to wear mass all the
time and it was really funny because
conservatives in the beginning were the
ones wearing masks
yes yeah i remember that there was one
point i was in
la and i had the n95 mask and those are
it protects you from breathing things in
filters it but then when you breathe out
it just breathes out that's right so it
doesn't protect you from the droplets of
it doesn't protect others others yeah
but that was the whole point of masks
but people didn't know and didn't care
because they would just see me and
they'd be like oh
he's got a mask on well they they then
banned them
and like neck gators and all that stuff
but man
is it but it was like the psychology of
it was more important than what they
were actually doing
i just noticed i just got to say you
know i remember when this first was
going down like when everything was
starting
and i had a bunch of people on the right
messaging me like get masks now you're
going to want to wear them
and then it's like this weird thing
started to happen where it started to
reflect
and i'm just like you know that's that's
hardcore tribalism
people were like wear masks then they
were like conservatives all of a sudden
decided not to wear that
i don't think it's tribalism i think
it's just being contrary i think that's
all there is to it good or bad
right no it's true it's tribalism i
think it's tribal yeah the conservatives
were our anti-establishment and wanted
to be contrarian
yeah so they decided and all of a sudden
they were going to defy the the orders
when the when fauci was saying don't
they were like you're crazy and they
went and bought masks
and then once it switched and all of a
sudden like trump didn't wear masks i
guess all of a sudden everyone's like
bah
it's just the weirdest thing well i mean
i think it's interesting to see how this
has unfolded
with the evolving knowledge we've had
about kobe because i remember when stuff
first started happening
i didn't go out because i was scared you
know my dad's immuno compromise
and things like that and we were getting
crazy footage out of wuhan like people
like collapsing in the
streets it was insane but then what's
weird is that as we found out more about
how covet spreads and about how lethal
it was and things like that
um you know for a lot of people i think
that would have been reason to
kind of ease up like oh okay it's not as
bad as we were thinking we didn't know
but now we actually have numbers in
but for a lot of people it was the
inverse they actually got more panicked
and that's because the media was
reporting on it more
even though all the data we were coming
in was good news for us
i think it's it's widely tribalist i
mean we heard from david hogg
he was like okay the cdc says if you're
vaccinated you take your mask off
but then people think i'm a conservative
so that's it
it's virtue signaling because they're
the
the the culture war tribes are so
distinct now there's there's people who
are
terrified of being viewed as a member of
the other tribe cnn really has a hand in
causing the fear too
veritas uncovered that guy explaining
that we would put the num the kova death
numbers on the screen intentionally
because it got interesting it got good
rev it got good views it got clicks it
got
it got good what do you call it yeah got
good ratings
gangbusters for the ratings gangbusters
have them have them
you know if it bleeds count yeah he was
pre
they were scaring people on purpose for
ratings
and now we're seeing like does that work
does that work you're like scaring
people well it
i mean it worked it works it gets
ratings but it actually destroys society
in the process so like is that working i
don't know
yeah so so so i could say something like
uh a viewers
there's there's vampires oh no
oh and there's and there's zombies and
werewolves they're everywhere
uh yeah you gotta be careful you're
orson are they gonna get if they get
scared now because people are scared
like
like people are scared of vampires our
ratings are gonna go up now yeah it's
possible they'll share the video
if you have connections to government
and you're able to actually hype up
government with your like own reporters
going up to let's say saki and saying
like what are you doing about the
vampire menace
i'm dr fauci and vampires are really bad
so wear your neck gators because they'll
bite your neck
i think um in the 20s wore the worlds
orson welles he had a radio show with
his theater group and they did this
this radio show called war the worlds
where they were like aliens are
attacking and then
people thought it was real so i i've
heard that some people were killing
themselves because they were so
they thought it was the end of the world
but people were like going out in the
street and like
looking up in the sky for the aliens
it's an urban legend it could be
ice i don't know i'll
a guy and a woman who are about to get
are they married or whatever yeah yeah
married
they're they're they're on the verge of
divorce because he won't take his mask
off during sex
and so the lady actually tells her like
the the the prudence or whatever
responds with like
take him to therapy yes and then if he
doesn't respond like
leave him what are you supposed to do
yeah
dude that's creepy no but that's that's
not anything to do with actual kobe like
covet is not the problem here there's
something
underlying that and i think that's it's
so true for all these other
authoritarians who are crazy and
obsessive about this
it's not really about the pandemic
because the numbers don't support it i
think it's
a form of social control it's it's it's
media derangement syndrome but you know
what i find fascinating is that it's
it's
it's a sorting algorithm essentially
right so there are free thinking
independent people who believe in
personal responsibility
these people have politics that vary
from economic left to economic right
so you'll get someone who's like you
know a disfacted liberal intellectual
dark web a moderate or a conservative
but then you have people who just don't
know don't care don't want to know don't
want to care
these are the kind of stories that are
shuffling them into two different groups
one group is a bunch of mindless drones
who believe
insane things trump is a russian agent
and then the other group are people who
are challenging the establishment
now don't get me wrong you got fringe
you know right ring people q
and whatever stuff but that's that's the
minority that's not
that's not a large faction and these way
to understand it is
the prominent conservative voices or the
prominent anti-woke
or anti-establishment voices are not
fringe
like they're not crazy they're rational
they're fairly moderate on the left the
prominent voices
are fringe wacko conspiracy theorists
like rachel maddow claiming that russia
was going to shut the [ __ ] up
what if russia shuts the power off to
fargo in the middle of the winter what
are we going to do and
you know donald trump russia and then
they had the guy jonathan chain on msnbc
who was like donald trump may be a
russian asset going back
as far as the 80s that's the mainstream
institutionalized left what's the worst
thing you get a republican party
the republican leadership it's an
oxymoron they're just like milk toast
mitch mcconnell's like well i'll barrel
speed bump for the democrats
and then you get what marjorie taylor
green that's the worst the republicans
can muster
essentially and what's frustrating is
that it
there's no long-term memory or heck even
short-term
term memory when it comes to defining
what is and what is not a conspiracy
theorist i mean we saw this with the
vaccine kovid wuhan lab thing
um you know we have screenshots of the
media just ripping apart trump for
saying that it could have come from a
lab and now it's like oh yeah maybe it
did
and it's it's funny how quickly that
narrative changes and it's based on
who's saying it
yeah fauci comes out and he says he's
not entirely convinced
that the the that kovid was uh naturally
occurring
and now all of a sudden all of these
stories are being just
flipped in think about how insane that
is because i'll tell you
headlines change because they realize
they were wrong
that means every link that used the
headline now has the incorrect headline
that doesn't change
you go on reddit and look up the
archives look up the rankings and you'll
see a story that says trump pushes
debunked conspiracy you click it and
then it says
you know update this is actually you
know like actually maybe
yeah so you look at wikipedia how many
articles
exist right on wikipedia that say things
and use those stories as references
that have now been changed see the
wikipedia editors aren't going to go
back to a bunch of these articles
some which may be obscure and change all
them so there you go
the whole system is is fried from this
this insanity and i don't know i don't
know what it is
i can tell you that we used to have
journalists that
i guess competed with each other but now
they all walk in lockstep
and it's all about social acceptance so
you could find i'll put it this way a
good journalist is always researching
conspiracy theories
because they hear a crazy story did you
hear about government politician who you
know was doing this and that
and imagine you know you go back to uh
the the
water gate imagine if someone came out
and was like richard nixon is
is doing this that and whatever oh
that's a conspiracy
theory oh you're nuts i'm not gonna
bother investigating that
could you imagine if that's how
journalism was back then at least they
did something about it
well they don't really investigate
things anymore i mean one of the only
investigative journalists
is james o'keefe now it seems like
journalists just go on twitter retweet
each other
talk to each other and there's no actual
like first
hand probing or investigating unless
it's like you know doxing some grandma
who voted for trump
in 2016 because russian facebook ads
yeah going to her house exactly and then
james o'keefe is the one who gets banned
because when you know he does something
similar
it's interesting about veritas because i
think
i think james is very obviously
conservative but
it's clear that you know the things he's
active about are much more about honesty
and journalism
and incorporations because he's not
doing stories
for the most part that are that are
benefiting some kind of republican
agenda in terms of taxes
or pro-life it's usually like we caught
someone lying
we got uh facebook's manipulating it
does benefit conservatives because
conservatives are getting censored for
sure
maybe that's just where conservatives
are at right now
but uh you look at vox and new york
times
and they want a political agenda they
want a hard outcome
they they specifically want what the
democrat wants or they're just willing
to say
say whatever they have to say to fit in
with democrats i think it has a lot to
do with social media
i think it has a lot to do with urban
centers
you know monopolizing journalism
basically so the people who work at the
new york times want to fit in
so what do they do sitting down at the
bar and they're in the back of their
brooklyn you know speakeasy whatever
and then one person says something and
the other person just says whatever you
say
tell me what to say and i'll say it
because i want to fit in the fitting in
things disturbing it does
suck to not fit in especially i mean
ostracization could lead to death
back in the ancient world if you're
thrown out of the city but unemployment
nowadays
and being cancelled off the internet man
it's pretty rough but still you know
falling in line to a corrupt system
seems way more dangerous than losing
access to it i would rather sleep in a
bin
in a dumpster than live on my knees for
these people
yeah you got to at some point why you
know i did that with the entertainment
industry in hollywood it was so gross
i could have been easily a millionaire i
was making you know
good money as a working commercials in
la and just
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members
only content segments you can't get
anywhere else go to timcast.com become a
member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you